bang-bang what's up guys lunch money
time while while she's trying to get
rich the rest of us just trying to get a
lunch money right come into you every
day around noon ish because we'd have
our [ __ ] together sometimes at noon
sometimes at 5:00 p.m. but we'll get it
to you every single day I have the
beautiful and intelligent plain of Mara
Nova today she looks like a traffic cone
we are ready to rock and roll
on a Monday traffic cones are not yellow
we'll go ahead and educate you on that
later they're orange slash ready let's
get into Warren Buffett they're the
Oracle of Omaha one of the richest men
talking about everything from America to
Airlines to buybacks did we watch that
or did I watch it and you got a second
hand and you just gave up at some point
you're like this is ridiculous no I
listened you did yeah all right so
Warren Buffett's got 135 plus billion
dollars of cash he's sitting there while
the economic downturns going on
everyone's saying when is Omaha going to
make a move he hasn't done anything yet
he's still sitting there in my big
takeaway was he thinks it's probably
going to get worse before it gets better
and at one point he got asked why have
you not bought any companies or provided
any financing he said we haven't seen
anything attractive yet which is a
pretty telling given that the stock
market went down 30% so I think that's
an interesting data point he also sold
100% of his airline stake would you know
what's going on the airline's why he did
that
um yes they're not doing well that's one
way to look at it so it'll last a while
and the effects of the Khronos for
decades he was very anti air lock
it'll last for decades no for decades
he's very anti Airlines he at one point
even wrote I think like 2007 something
to the effect of if a capitalist had
been at Kitty Hawk when the Orville
brothers Orville Wright and his brother
took flight they would have shot down
the plane saying like these are horrible
investments but in 2016 he surprised
everybody and he took a major stake
seven and ten percent in four separate
us-based Airlines the four largest
airlines in the United States he held it
for what ended up being about four years
and he completely sold the position my
take is that he thinks that the
economics those businesses are gonna get
screwed up because demand is down so
much you know what I thought was
interesting then he said what he said
that being against stock buybacks is now
politically correct but there's nothing
wrong with my backs so think about that
there's nothing wrong with a buyback
because it's a tax efficient way to
return value back to shareholders the
problem becomes when you tie the
executive compensation to the buyback
Beeker to the stock price because what
it does is it changes the incentives and
now the executives are incentivized to
take on debt and then use that debt to
then go buy back their shares to prop up
the stock price so that they make more
money personally so cheese be in centre
structure but we'll get to some debt
some over-leveraged companies in a
couple of minutes but before we do that
he was also asked about the Federal
Reserve he was actually very
congratulatory towards Federal Reserve
he spoke very fondly Paul Volcker who
recently passed away said hey that was
probably the best Fed Chairman but the
folks today are doing a pretty good job
he was very impressive how quickly they
acted and the fact they used the
2008-2009 financial crisis playbook in
order to help prop up markets we think
good I'm sure
all right you don't seem very Warren
Buffett fan today no I you do why I
think he's a very sharp man yeah 89
years old yeah pretty crazy all right
PPP number three what's going on there
there could be a third round of PPP
small business loans coming as demand
surges you know who said that
larry cudlow larry cudlow is gonna end
up being the joke of this whole thing so
larry cudlow is he he's like the
National Economic Council director or
something like that
and this is why Larry Kudlow is a joke
Larry Kudlow when the stock market went
down like five 10% went on national
television and Toyota went buy stocks
right and then a week later when stocks
had continued to fall he went back on
television they asked him about he said
oh you should buy stocks and so his
whole thing here is he's trying to
establish confidence in the market I get
what he's trying to do but I want to
know what is Larry Kudlow sport folio
what is Larry Kudlow been doing with his
money
what's his cash position how much stock
is he buying how much is he selling what
is he shorting you shouldn't be able to
go on national television in the
position that he's in and say buy stocks
make a specific investment
recommendation without tonus what you're
doing with your portfolio because if
people realized let's say that he was
shorting stocks or he was selling stocks
why he was saying that people people who
just have a huge public it's unethical
right right but we don't know what he's
doing and therefore were operating we're
listening to somebody's advice who's in
a position of power and influence in the
government that is not telling us what
he's doing with his portfolio why should
we listen that what's in your wall a
commercial Capital One no sponsorships
here no sponsorships here PPP number
three though is the Paycheck protection
program they did 350 billion the first
time 310 billion so what is that that's
660 billion if my math is correct and
now they're talking about they may
actually need to do a third round of
this hundreds of billions of dollars
more it's not confirmed been watching
lunch money who said this could happen
are you oh you're on fire today traffic
cone outfit on and they say you know
you're like you're just directing
traffic all over the place alright
what's going on with Tesla Tesla so I
mean Elon Musk you know like every so
often he says something controversial I
feel like it had been a while since he
said the last controversial thing so
here he is again I don't know if he was
serious or if he was joking or if he was
high but he said Tesla stock price is
too high in my opinion he tweeted this
tweeted it to millions of followers and
the stock price paint if you're a Tesla
shareholder you're probably pissed off
because he just destroyed 15
billion dollars of value was he being
sarcastic no he probably was being dead
serious and it probably is a rebellion
like at the time he said it probably was
what was the price that he said it like
757 seventy something like that right so
there was seven hundred seventy dollars
give or taking it phone around seven
hundred bucks
and so down ten percent people like oh
my god that's crazy but there's a lot of
people who actually think that the stock
is overvalued if he believes that one
that could argue like at least he's
saying it how many CEOs either think
their stocks are were valued and don't
say that's ridiculous why it's
ridiculous they should be allowed to say
what they believe okay right as long as
we know again what is he doing is he
buying or selling shouldn't he act in
the best interest of shareholders that
was not in the best interest of
shareholders there's an argument to be
said yes that but also too he could be
protecting shareholders saying hey the
company's overvalued right now right it
depends on how you until your value he
created hundreds of billions of billions
of beyond that then he started tweeting
don't need the cash devoting myself to
Mars and Earth possessions just weigh
you down yeah he's just a free spirit
lady talking about it's about respira
about to have a baby one is he yeah I
don't think any I don't think he's gonna
happen at me right but he is out here
talking about how positions don't what
he said he's gonna sell all of his
possessions including his house doesn't
need anything whatever gonna live he's
gonna rent doesn't need to own that
house why doesn't he just rent the whole
thing is that yes he says some crazy
controversial stuff he's probably one of
the brightest minds that we have course
but it's just like I feel like he I feel
like he's sitting at home and he's like
shaking he's like I haven't said
anything controversial in three months I
got it I got him dude well he said a lot
of controversial stuff he when he came
out against coronavirus oh yeah even
before that I feel like it had been a
while yeah counting that into this do
you want to know do what seal on must
birthday I think day is born in June so
you know who else was born in June don't
tell me
let's see what his birthday is oh sorry
come on come on hurry you got to be
quick on the sticks here June 28th I
told you he's born in June you know who
else is born in June Kanye West you
wanna know who else is born in June
Donald Trump one knows who else is born
in June
all the psychos I just think it's
hysterical that all these people saying
crazy [ __ ] on on Twitter are all born in
June all right wasn't morning June yeah
exactly the traffic cone all right
what's going on with J crew what I
thought was interesting is they said
they said the retailer expects to stay
in business and emerge from bankruptcy
as a profitable company what yes
so bankruptcy two points here chapter 11
well two points here it's an over
leveraged company these companies got
raided by private equity firms who came
in and said I'm gonna buy your company
I'm gonna put all this debt on it I'm
gonna use your cash flow to pay off that
debt I'm gonna extract tons and tons of
value I bet you there's companies that
made billions of dollars off a j.crew
investment firms and now j-cruise gonna
file for bankruptcy but a lot of people
forget bankruptcy does not mean that the
stores just vanish right or the
employees all get fired bankruptcy is a
protective legal process that says we
are going to restructure this company
and we will then allow it to continue to
operate after the fact and so when that
occurs you get something like what take
crews about to go through well they will
literally take those companies they will
get new ownership a new capital stack
and when it comes out they'll have been
able to do things that they couldn't do
outside of bankruptcy so they can go to
people that they owe money and say we're
not gonna pay you right we're gonna file
bankruptcy all this kind of stuff so
overall it's gonna be a good thing but
the virus is accelerating trends online
commerce versus in-store retail to
private equity firms that over leveraged
these companies and suck all the value
out not only do I one think that it's
incredibly bad practice but obviously -
it screws up these companies and 3 is
the employee most of the employees will
be ok because they're in this protection
status but at the same time bankruptcy
is not fun for anybody
j.crew you shop at j.crew oh not really
do you want to know who else tops a
j.crew that i know no it was carroll
[ __ ] basket all right what's going on
with the speaking of murder in Carroll
Baskin what's going on with the murder
you see that transition I should I
should be like a host go ahead murder
Hornets so the murder Hornet is
something that could make 2020 even more
exciting than it is today the New York
Times has a story about that's a story
about this giant Asian Hornet that is
really really large and it what does it
say it can fly it speeds up to 20 miles
per hour and there's things are
described as feeling like red-hot
thumbtacks they're scary
there's huge the photo of them they're
like twice as big as a normal ordinary
50 people per year die from it in Japan
wait can I ask a really simple but very
intelligent question how does this
Hornet get so it's now in the u.s. how
does it get from Asia to the US well
Miss Polina they fly 20 miles an hour
well I'm sure that the migration
happened slowly over time or another
crazy thing would be maybe maybe it was
like you know what I want to be like the
Christopher Columbus of murder Hornets
and so it just got on like a ship you
kind of just the ship came to America
and then it hopped off was like are you
scared that it might kill people in the
United States
I mean honestly at this point that would
make 2020 like complete that would make
2020 like a horror movie the murder
Hornets are here so it's scary the name
murderer Hornet obviously is scary but
it really doesn't kill people it kills
50 people a year that's like nothing
it's like getting struck by lightning
say that to the people who died it's
literal it's called Vespa
Amanda Renea it's a cabeza ok scientists
pull you know that last dance what's
going on with last dance
oh so you watch the last dance
documentary again last night
what episode numbers 4 & 5 5 & 6 5 & 6
nice good job way to pay attention
and what happened what do you remember
oh I met Toni Kukoc Oh Toni Kukoc is
featured man no he was getting abused he
was getting abused like a little boy
literally getting abused on the corner
what you know what he's country all
these dudes were like Oh
Toni's soft whatever this country was
going to a civil war when he was in the
Olympics and episode make you tough oh
my god
I know easy hold on time out this is a
fallacy right fallacy is a tumor just
because your country is going through
war if you're not participating in the
war that doesn't make you tough he's
playing basketball he's literally at the
Olympics how tough is he he's at the
Olympics I could make the argument that
I could make the argument that he's
actually soft because he decided he will
play basketball rather than go fight in
the war
no he and his he decided to stay and
play in Europe for a few more years so
that he could be near his family is all
this it's a food stuff crazy war if
you've seen the documentary what is it
once brother's really good I think thank
you yes it's the same war when he was
Slavia kind of tore apart anyway alibies
all these bros who've never been through
anything oh he's soft and then he came
back and did it again and it was better
and I like Toni Kukoc I would gladly be
Toni Kukoc okay ready did you like the
documentary thumbs up or thumbs down on
the Michael Jordan documentary thumbs up
did you see that fun fact that you sent
me that apparently the documentaries not
even completely finished but they
started releasing it because people are
in quarantine they were supposed to
release it in June they sped it up to
April on ESPN and some of the early
episodes were done but right now the
reason why they're releasing them over a
number of weeks is because they're
literally finishing the final episodes
now they're still cutting a love so much
pressure a little bit would you like
about last dance
Michael Jordan's just a gangster like he
is so competitive it didn't matter what
it was my favorite part of the whole
thing is when he's standing in is like
little private room in the locker room
and he's literally throwing coins
cooking
closest to the wall and he's gambling
with the security guards like they're
sitting there literally throwing it who
can get it closest to the wall that's
something that like degenerates do and
you know what's really funny so it's
like when I play chess with you so I
beat him really bad last time now he
won't play chess with me good we play
almost every day and I've won twice as
many games as you have but you know what
I noticed about Michael Jordan is that
very similarly to you when you win it's
all oh it's my ability I'm so good but
when the other person whose rig is
rigged you're cheating that's right oh
it's rigged and that's what Michael
Jordan told the security guard he was
like I don't know like your your point
like rolls and he goes watch this money
roll in my pocket no but it's like
that's part of the enjoyment of being
competitive is talking [ __ ] it's so nice
when I beat you in chess and I know I
got you and I start talking [ __ ] and I'm
like you got nowhere to go and you get
mad that's part of the I don't want to
hear I don't hear I'll teach you I'll
teach you how to talk [ __ ] you'll have
so much more fun competing you've got
all this is a lot of fun like taking a
little victory laps but then you got a
thick skin so that when somebody beat
you you don't cry I don't know that's
ever happened
go ahead sad deals what's going on
speaking of crying beside heels guys so
there's this aquarium in Japan that has
these eels and because of quarantine the
yosef gotten really shy because they
haven't had human contact so now the
aquarium is asking people to volunteer
to face time with the eels
who holds the phone know they set up
tablets around the tank and the eels are
just like what's up yeah they would come
out of their cage they very they bury
themselves in the sand which is kind of
what I want to do right now but they
bury themselves in the sand cuz they're
sad and shy and then they come out and
they just look and they look yeah do
they talk do you know what sound the
eels make
that yes that you'll noise everybody
knows that you never practiced that as a
little kid like what's a dog doing
everyone barks and like what's a cat do
then you know what's it LLL do one time
I had a few glasses of wine and I try to
thinking like what sound does a giraffe
make what do you know it's something so
I looked it up what's the noise
kind of like that no come on make the
noise no it's kinda like that what's the
noise no you're you're being a you're
not being any fun today all right good
listen but do we think that this is
going on with other animals and zoos as
well like like the eels are kind of and
you know they're eels is fine like they
live in the water or whatever it's not
like humans like going in the water all
time with them but like imagine if
you're like a monkey and you're like man
it's so much fun to mess with all those
people when they come here a monkey have
their monkey friends do the eels not
have your friends not really they're
kind of solitary and they have what do
you an eel expert oh yeah they go back
to their cautious wild nature all right
but actually you're kind of like a human
version of an eel you just go bury
yourself on the couch sometimes and make
weird noises like all right what's going
on low lunch money later bang bang
who is the winner ha ha no all right we
followed you on Twitter we're trying
yeah here we go
the joke was I'm fully invested in
watching your videos that's really
really good
so onna go ahead and you have to follow
me back so I can DM you so that we can
send you the money but you are the
winner
please follow back so that I can DM you
and plan I really like this one
thankfully she's not wearing her best
today she's just write her traffic cone
out there no problem you never know when
you got a direct so traffic
yeah we have one minute left 60 seconds
do you have anything any takeaways from
the weekend any news for the people and
he messages anything to look forward to
this week you can look forward to lunch
money and being kind to your friends
that's your message what's your message
my message is uh get money get paid can
I steal it from you
Planet planta is very a little
me right now because along with the
murder Hornets
I also told her yesterday while we're
sitting on the couch did you know what
the cobra is and she was like what's
that and I hit her with one of these and
I whacked it right on the head the Cobra
and the murder Hornets we got a whole
little in a little zoo of murderous
animals going on all right we're gonna
get through this together all right guys
listen thanks so much for for watching
today lunch money well while she's
trying to get rich the rest of us just
trying to get our lunch money right
smash the like button subscribe to the
channel leave a comment we will do our
best to answer all of them did you
notice he shaved his beard yummy so
maybe other day commented that your
beard needed a v-shaped recovery well I
got a v-shaped recovery 1 & 2 I actually
I had shaved them mustache this morning
and I looked and I looked and planet was
still sleeping because she likes to
sleep in unlike the rest of us not and
while she was sleeping I was heavily
considering leaving the mustache are you
gonna tell people he told me a joke that
should never be repeated oh I was gonna
start out the episode with hello I must
ask you a question she's not the only
one with dad jokes around here all right
guys listen that's it for today we
appreciate you watching subscribe like
comment and let us know in the comments
what uh what do you think of Polina and
all of her bad jokes we'll see you guys
tomorrow